so this movie about a cocaine bear did
very very well at the box office and I
think people have spoofed it with like
cocaine shark and other things so many
things whatever but I'm I am curious
though with the success of the film have
you actually talked to the studio about
what more can we do with the COC genre
and movie you know what I mean I mean
the studio is always interested in
replicating success you know um I don't
know that we've on the exact thing um
but of course I'm open to anything I
like to think of this movie as cocaine
Ducks yeah it could be they're I mean
just like a few F bombs thrown in yeah
and also we should go to Jamaica that's
a very slly crazier bad guy and like we
would get there really quickly we're
certainly acting like we're all on drugs
and the that Chef definitely oh he's
definitely on something what's really
funny is I said to Benjamin I go like
you have a a chef je a kitchen and um
I'm like you're basically playing a
little bit in the Ratatouille land very
Ratatouille those sections how how
nervous were you to take that on because
you're playing in the Ratatouille world
and he actually talked all about it also
uh Little Mermaid has a great scene with
the chef and crab I mean these are
classic animation tropes honestly people
love we always worry you the greatest
danger that the animals are in is that
we are going to eat them come on that's
always the chicken run I mean have you
seen these this is like that's the Peril
that they're all worried about do you
remember when Chicken Run came out
Burger King had a tie in where they had
their chicken nuggets shaped like the
airplane that the chickens are building
to get out which I thought was really
taunting them like we killed you and
turned you into the shape that you used
to try and
Escape love Burger King have it your way
yeah sorry I I heard the ad in my head
so I went ask different question besides
migration um uh little curveball you
both have done really cool stuff in your
career what is the most nervous you've
been the night before the first day of
filming for whatever project it was
being like Oh my God I can't believe I'm
going to have to do this a good question
I know what mine was what was it well oh
it's interesting I I this is probably a
lie actually I've just realized I'm GNA
say my original answer that came into my
head which is Mrs America Kate Blanchett
and Margot marale two acting Idol of
mine and Tracy man I had to go to set
and act with them in Toronto and they
had already all been working and I kind
of flew in the night before I hate that
feeling so there are it's like I'm like
new girl I have no idea what the energy
is and the vi yeah exactly and I showed
up and I was really nerv I was like I
got to know all my lines I cannot not
know my lines in front of these acting
goddesses and then I got there and they
were like singing show tunes and it was
so fun and I was like oh this is going
to be no problem but man I was I went so
prepared to that set yeah well that's
great isn't it yes to me that's what it
is there preparation defeats nerves so I
always really prepare I never sleep the
night before a new job even though uh
you know no matter what the job is and
it's not always nerves sometimes it's
excitement yeah but also sometimes
you're playing a character you haven't
really played anything like that before
and you show up and you're like I've
done so much work and what if after the
first three takes they're like can you
do a different approach to me that's
terrifying right I can't even imagine uh
I I could never do what you guys do and
give you all the credit in the world um
jumping back into migration I really
enjoyed this movie like I'm being very
sincere with you like it it was a real
surprise I did not you thought I was
going to suck no I've seen a lot of
whatever animated movies and this is not
one of those whatever movies I will
strongly endorse this one thank you what
are you guys really looking forward to
audiences seeing I think that I think
it's going to surprise people that it's
deep deeper than you know a lot of other
animated movies and it looks absolutely
gorgeous it's really funny but it look
the way it looks I mean it's one of the
best looking movies I've ever seen I was
think it's surprisingly relatable as a
family adventure movie you know like
they're you know they're kind of The
Griswalds in one sense in that you know
everything's hilarity ensuing and you
know things are going wrong left and
right but the dynamic within the family
is is just it's like very real I think
we did a good job of not it's not overly
sacran or you know too jokey it's just
like just the right balance it's really
a real it really feels like a real
family all all five of us do well the
other thing I really liked about it is
there were no like dumb jokes like all
the jokes felt earned and they were
based on you know what I mean like yeah
that's great we no cheap shots so which
which cartoon do you think had a lot of
dumb jokes I don't want to pick out any
movies but I will say that that
yikes I'm not going to say I can only
get myself in trouble on I'm realizing
oh wait there are cameras on me perhaps
I should hold this one back I will just
move on to something else and talk about
efforts do you enjoy recording efforts
oh my God or do you like get me the F
that's the worst I think at the end
where they're like just do a bunch of
when when you go yeah you have the sheet
and at the end it just says effort it's
one word but you know it's going to take
so long it's so much work different
levels screaming screaming jumping
kicking sighing there's so many crying
yeah yeah just do a scream okay now do a
short scream now do a really long scream
okay now do like split the difference
like no context you know what I mean
cont like we don't know where we're
going to put it in the movie you're like
but where would this go we're not sure
we just want you to do it yeah is it a
happy scream or a scared scream or an
angry scream yes do them all last
question for both of you um individual
um I'm a fan of when you're directing do
you know if you're directing anything I
looked on IMDb and I saw some stuff but
I wasn't sure so I'm just asking you I
don't know when I'm directing when
anyone will see my efforts again but I
will I promise I will direct again that
is a that well I hope I mean now I'm
saying it I'm probably jinxing it no no
no no you when the movie is successful
they let you make another well I'm
hoping that they somebody lets me make
it something you've all your all your
movies have been great individual
question for you um you have done and I
said at the beginning some really cool
stuff in your career uh what but what
does it mean to be in the new
Ghostbusters movie it means the most to
me because it truly was my first
favorite movie I remember I don't just
remember the first time I saw
Ghostbusters I remember the first time
someone told me about
Ghostbusters uh I watched it both of
those one and to over and over and over
and over I can recite both of those
entire movies I love the cartoon the
animated The Real Ghostbusters so for me
you know it's truly truly your dream
come true who do you play What's the
role can you say uh I I don't know what
I can say uh I I can't say I can't I
don't think I could say I I don't want
to get you in trouble I was like you
know I know I I mean it's they're so
strict about these things so I don't
know if I can say I will leave it there
and say we will talk once I've seen the
film congratulations on this and uh you
guys have a fantastic day nice talking
to
you